[Applause]
i saw
a absolutely phenomenal tv series
this weekend okay i watched the entire
season i think it was only five episodes
yep they're about like 45 minute
episodes yeah
and uh the new season that just dropped
it's called chef's table
okay and uh basically they're these like
long-form stories
where they dive into a chef and
the style of cooking that he or she does
and also their story
right how they came to be how they came
to be this successful
and their restaurant and this
season is about barbecue specifically
and i cried i think it almost every
episode
these are so well done so beautiful
they're not about the food to me
what they're about is the ones that
really got me
are people learning
how to dream hmm
okay walk me through it i love a show
that is about something outside of the
show okay
they trick you into thinking it's a show
about a high school football team
but it's really about your passions your
love your sacrifice whatever friday
night lights was really about you know
and i'm watching the show about these
shifts
and i swear to god akash i think the
closest thing
to being a stand-up comic is being a
chef
that's fine people go oh comey's just
like boxing like all these nerd comics
that never [ __ ] stepped in the ring
before that comes just like
it's nothing like boxing i used to box
nothing like it at all yeah
when you go into the boxing ring the
person standing in front of you doesn't
want you to beat the [ __ ] out of them
right that's stand up yeah the guy paid
money to laugh at you
right the guy in a boxing ring wants to
kill you right
very different experience right
this chef's table
the amount of time and energy
that they put in so like innovating and
making that dish
right so that you can enjoy it
and their night is made uh
based on you liking it or hating it just
like validation
comes from you liking it yeah my friend
my good friend brian who you met is a
chef and we
we identify so much with like so much of
my self-worth is this this food right
here
that you love and that makes me feel
good or you're like
and that [ __ ] crushes me it's like
bombing because it is bombing yeah and
he puts his creativity into it
he puts his time into his passions love
his innovation how can i change this
dish how can i make this dish better
what can i do to make it better
and there's these fascinating stories of
different people but there's this common
theme which is like learning how to
dream
right like this guy named rodney scott
he's from like this really small town in
south carolina
and like he was told that you know
in high school all he was going to do
was go down the block and start cooking
up hogs
or whatever and like
that's what he did on his graduation day
and he thought that he was nothing more
than i think one of like
the greatest things i've ever gotten if
i have any privilege in this world
it is my parents
teaching me how to dream like ever since
i was young
just dream i've never thought there was
something i couldn't do because i just
dream it and then eventually
that is the the biggest um
hindrance to so many people right is the
idea of just even dreaming
of this thing that you want to create
conquer do
right and this guy thought he was just
gonna be there making he was depressed
his dad had like a stroke he had to take
over the business
and then he started taking over the
business he started like getting a
little creative and like making some
changes in the business
and like you can as he tells the story
like you can see him reliving him
finding confidence
right and then he was scared to go out
and branch out of his little town
right and then his barbecue burnt down
ah
and then he started to branch out and do
something like pop-up barbecues and
finally this guy was like please come to
charleston south carolina right which to
us maybe it doesn't seem like a big city
but to him when he's coming from this
tiny little town to go to charleston
rhodes is yeah the [ __ ] biggest thing
in the world right
and he finally like gets the courage to
go do it and he ends up winning
best chef in the southeast of america
and you can as he's telling the story
you can see
his self-esteem just inflating right
and he's like okay now we just got to
see how far we can push it what we can
do next well we can take this
let's go some other city how many other
cities i want to take over the world you
see a guy go from
i'm never going to be in anything than
this guy that cooks hogs down the block
too i'll
take my restaurant i put it wherever the
[ __ ] i want and it's like the most
beautiful feeling
because there's one thing i could ever
give anybody it was the ability to dream
yeah i don't care if there's one [ __ ]
thing i think that little kernel that
little seed you put inside anybody
that is that and some hard work is all
they need
for success you might not accomplish
every single thing but you're going to
accomplish more
yeah without that billy i'm telling you
this show is so beautifully done
go watch this show everybody listen
right now go watch this show
you should check it out as a comic i
think you'll listen to it someone who's
like
just passionate yeah about your craft
yeah
like seeing them innovate i relate to it
so much
how can we do things different right how
can we change things like
i'm seeing these i'm seeing these guys
there's this restaurant in chicago
this [ __ ] chef with three michelin
star restaurant
one of the best restaurants in the world
gets tongue cancer
and loses oh [ __ ] his sense of taste
yeah he loses
i mean this is almost like out of a
cartoon story or something like that
lose a sense of taste it's like
beethoven with music
he has to he has to make dishes with his
brain
and they developed a system where it's
like based on the salt level
he's like okay is it salty like a pickle
that'd be a five is it salty like you
know like bread that'd be one or
something like that
and based on that he's able to like put
together these crazy dishes
innovating like he finds a way to like
make sugar
float and you like drink balloons
i mean it's just they're crazy things
they're doing and they're just going how
can i push this further how can i make
something innovative different yeah and
i was so [ __ ] inspired by it man
i'm gonna watch this you guys gotta
check it out yeah i mean it was so good
the guys who made it i hope that they
listen or somebody tells them
about this because i think they did such
a [ __ ] incredible job of like
getting into the story getting into the
characters but also like getting into
like what the ethos of the show was
yeah and i always think of these things
like
you know people will ask like as far as
a career goes like the decisions
that we've made you know in
like what is the competitive advantage
you know maybe we've had and i've always
thought it was like bravery i think
anybody who like
looks at the industry can see trends i
don't think i'm like unique in that
regard like i think you just sit down
there long enough and you go oh yeah i
think everything's going towards the
internet i think everything's going
towards youtube or
you know even like going towards short
clips and that kind of stuff but like
we will do it you know we were flagrant
when it was not the right time to be
flagrant right
but we knew that that's what the people
needed
yeah you know we knew that's what the
craving was we knew this was going to
come to an end pc was going to come to
an end
absolutely you know and it's like i
don't always
i was just so cool to see it was like
refreshing to see these other people in
a completely different field but like
view their craft the same way
yeah you know like i remember like after
doing the views from the
sys special like i was like how do i go
further with this like what is
okay we did these crazy jokes okay
there's all these people in the crowd
like what is
what it what what can i do differently
how can i create a different experience
like yeah i go okay like what if i just
what if i just make the jokes up on the
spot right
you know and and i remember like looking
at the people i admired how they did
crowd work
and i was like okay how can i do this
different like what can i change about
crowd work
and then i remember going like okay if
people ask
what is the typical question with crowd
work it's like so what do you do
yeah i remember going all right but what
if i
don't do the jokes about what they do
but what if i do the jokes about
who they are like what if i'm talking to
you about your identity
right who you are what you believe in
that's the highest stakes
that's if it goes badly you're super
offended
you're [ __ ] pissed off and it could
be really awkward but if it goes
great the [ __ ] sky's the limit right
right and it's like on that
that little thin line between like
success and failure is
every cooking a little too much salt
destroys the dish right
right and a little too much edge
whatever it is could destroy that bit
at that person and it's like how do we
find the [ __ ] way to do it how do you
find a way to
create that even with what the monologue
shows it was like okay we can't do live
shows how do we do comedy without an
audience
right how do we figure that [ __ ] out
yeah how do we switch little things so
it's not uncomfortable you tell a joke
and to avoid
i don't know i just think that you'd
appreciate it so much i think anybody
who like
is passionate about whatever the [ __ ]
their craft is i think they'd find
a lot of joy in it absolutely check it
out yeah
you got it you got did you watch it yet
now no not yet i think you and also just
the cinematography is [ __ ] great like
it's also dope to watch
people at any at a high level of
anything talking about it
yes there's [ __ ] you won't understand
with the nuances of the whatever if it's
cooking dishes
talking funny yeah with seinfeld and
rock and louisiaka
all right there's new on [ __ ] you only
get if you're a comic but also just talk
listening to people do anything at a
high level talk about yes
that thing is like there's a passion
that comes through there's an emotion
that you feel that resonates with
something inside of you that's like
oh this is dope there's one part that
you're gonna love
and you'll be there for the whole you
know experiments if you watch it
but one of the chefs uh he has again
this is the chicago one who lost his
sense of taste and then it came back
eventually but um
he has the most successful restaurant in
chicago
people are spending crazy amount of
money it's amazing
yeah and he keeps changing the menu
and people like what the [ __ ] are you
doing we're sold out
yeah people are going to come here it's
going to be new people it's not the same
people you don't have to worry about
doing the same dish
or jokes over and over again
right yeah he got tired of his material
like we get tired of our material it's
not for you it's for me
it's for he says it i miss why i wish i
was watching it with y'all man
because like he goes he goes if we do a
greatest hits
he goes that's great of dishes he goes
to me that's the death that's the death
of cooking the death of creation they
have crest and desperation all right
literally that's the death of creation
yeah that's the opposite
we're not creating anymore we're not
pushing we're not trying we're not
trying to find something to do it's like
this is the new thing now
doing the monologue is a new thing now
we're going to create a new thing later
we're going to create a new thing after
that we're going to
be that's what we do we like creating
there's no passion in it to the point
that i look at people who can do the
same joke over and over
with a certain level of envy like how
you do this thing with no passion
because how do you find passion in the
same thing over them because they're
addicted to the
results not the act they're they're not
addicted to creation they're addicted to
the result
of that thing yeah right so they're like
oh i get the collapse okay i'm fine as
long as i'm getting claps
i won't write anything new but once i
stop getting collapsed then i'll write
new
yeah we get claps on some [ __ ] that we
write and then eventually we're like
all right i think i'm done with that
yeah it gets to the point i know i'm
done with the bit where i hate them for
laughing at it i'm like
[ __ ] yeah i'm such a loser oh you're
laughing this
dog [ __ ] i know there's a thousand times
you regular as
a [ __ ]
it's just you are addicted to the
creation
that's the sign of true creative yeah
and that's the thing where like
you see like these um oftentimes like
corporate structures exist right yeah
and what they do is they don't
they're set up for people who are not
creating
right there it's a moat to protect what
exists
and is yeah and stop letting innovation
in because they cannot continuously
innovate
what's the idea of a monopoly right if i
just control all
uh other things i don't need to make
anything new also there's safety
in not being creative i know this is
monetizable
i know i can make money on these dishes
it's a line out the door what are you
creating for don't create stop
creating and if you're not a creative
that works perfectly matter of fact
create creativity
threatens you it frightens the [ __ ] out
of you yeah right
someone who could come along and create
something cooler than your [ __ ] yeah
you squash him yep i need to i need to
shut him down i need to make sure he's
not doing anything
it's terrifying yeah the internet
terrifies these [ __ ] because
now we can come out here we can create
our [ __ ]
and we could put that [ __ ] pressure
and make them have to change as well
and that's what yeah that's what
comedies become they're they're caving
yeah you know it's funny another thing
about i remember one of the reasons i
didn't ever get an agent
is they would ask how many minutes do
you have and i would have no [ __ ]
clue
yeah because i don't think about comedy
and like getting six minutes or seven
minutes or eight minutes
i'm always trying to do a new joke i'll
definitely do i need validation i'm not
some [ __ ] guy who's
a bombing so i'll do the joke sometimes
that i love but for the most part i
don't want to do those i want to be
doing new [ __ ]
so when you say how many minutes do i
have i will go i can do as long as you
need me to do
how many minutes do i have i have no
[ __ ] clue i haven't formulized
i haven't made my comedy that formulaic
then i know this is three minutes and
that's two minutes and how the [ __ ] do
y'all even do that
right and to somebody who's not
passionate about it that's terrifying
yep so you almost got to get to the
highest level you got to be the guy
who's
lying out the door and then you've
proven you can keep changing it for them
to finally go i let them do [ __ ]
things
yeah 100 and there is a balance which
i'm sure that you've reached which is
like
where you were going to say something
album oh yeah no i was just saying it's
cool hearing you guys talk about your
creativity from a comedic stance and
when i first got into this i didn't
think of myself as a creative i was like
oh i just
enjoyed doing it since it was like a
hobby that became
something i was good at was like all
right and then i realized i
kept catching myself trying new things
like once yeah i got good at something i
was like oh i want to do something
that's my favorite thing oh
[ __ ] is like it's old to me and even
though people still like it it's like ah
that's still the old [ __ ]
and like hearing you guys talk about
this every time like
now when i do little additives in a
little
instagram clip yup only should i care
about are the people who notice those
little nuances is like oh that [ __ ] was
dope that's the only [ __ ] i like yeah
that's that's what i'm doing because
that's your creative outlet it's like
like just like cooking is their creative
outlet yeah and there's someone on that
cooking team
and what he does is [ __ ] salad yeah
and he finds a way to make that salad
slap
yeah you know like he might put the
salad on the grill
right like who knows you trying to find
a new way to get some flavors out of it
when i start working with a person for
like camera work i always start editing
or whatever i'm like yo
i want you to try everything that's what
that's how alex got so nice try
every you're that's like the thing i
like most about you is i'm always trying
to find a little thing to do that's
different this is so sweet yeah
but it's true i love this guy nah dude
you gotta let people go
like i love y'all dude love y'all man
love y'all
taylor you know taylor said
yeah you gotta say it i love you taylor
[Music]
um
you know what i mean you could say it to
drew andrew [ __ ] up
andrew schultz alex media you work with
every week you can't say it
i love you all yes thank you thank you
we'll take the group one even though it
don't mean as much
it's safer it's a safer version but that
is just to wrap it up but that is an
interesting thing about like
how create how threatening creativity is
and like how people try to control those
environments
yeah right and like don't get me wrong
work being able to like mix with the
mainstream is important like
you've recognized throughout your career
and we've had conversations about this
like
you know that you need to have an hour
you know you need to have
x amount of minutes if you're going to
do this so if we're going to do a
project that's 15 minutes long you know
you need to have that ironed out and
we've had these conversations
it's not that and and the people who are
truly successful
understand how to function within the
rigidity
of these structures and the creativity
of absolutely zero inhibitions
and zero limitations right and like
blending those things together and
that's what these chefs do
and that's what successful comics end up
doing yeah you can't be too much
rigid because there's no creativity and
you can't be too much just creative
because
you can't monetize that yeah you want to
just go tell jokes into a wall go for it
yeah great that's not the business right
you want to be in the business right
like if you want to be in the business
yeah you're signing up it's like you
want to play for the nba you can play
pickup you want to play in the nba be in
shape to play 48 minutes because that's
how long it'll get the [ __ ] game you
want to dribble however you want to
dribble
that and one [ __ ] once you go for it
yeah go be as creative as you want to
here
you'd be creative within this offense
exactly and there's
yeah so anyway i just think it's so i
think it's so cool and i just think that
like
it's great to see other people look at
stuff the way you do yeah
and i'm sure there's people listening to
this podcast and they're not stand-ups
but they're in advertising or they're in
these other fields and they're like oh
yeah the way you talk about stand-up is
kind of how i feel about
advertising i feel about art or whatever
it is and it's like yeah [ __ ]
innovate
put that foot on their neck you should
absolutely do that
[Applause]
you